on va accueillir à nos copains nos
garçons puisque c'est un spécial face à
une spéciale cloclo miliani avec cloclo
hier soir sur tmc qui a très bien marché
un dock se fera partie d'ailleurs des
trophées des audiences mais pour le
moment enfin toc toc toc spécial cloclo
c'est parti toc toc toc toc toc à ela
stone stan qui s année là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quoi
qu'on a dit adieu à marie est d'accord
et c'est une de mes chansons préférées
de cloclo super reprises par m pokora
aux prises par matt pokora et yannick ou
pas yannick toi et adéquate et robert
bien sûr ces soirées-là aller voter -
elle est avec votre corps ouais mais en
chorégraphie c'est vrai que vous êtes
vraiment et en cela c'est vraiment bon
m'appelle kamel ouali est déjà parti qui
est là
djamel qu'amélie djamel je te rejoins
maison travaille pas pas vous je sais
inquiétez pas il va sortir
il va sortir c'est sur cette île et ces
fraudes
vous avez répété ça oui ouais bah alors
ne fait peut-être pas le prix mini non
mais sérieux et mes dents mais quel
rapport en fait c'est même pas compris
c'est jamel jamel m
et je te bouscule tu ne te réveille pas
encore sur quoi je remonte
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bernard n'y a pas pu choquer dit non non
c'est ma fille voilà quoi cali c'est
votre vie c'est une grande révélation ce
soit n'arrête pas de dire des cégétistes
papa aussi mais vous non je pas son papa
- frère un grand frère comme c'est comme
mon frère ma petite soeur ça me fait
penser à un truc
ouais tu dois partir non
le plus
ou pas il a tweeté ce matin isabelle
notre maman a tous je te ramène l'écart
qu'on a en année oui c'est quoi l'écart
entre vous de ces 60 ans est la santé
cds imite votre grande tante mais pas
votre maire d'ecully
non franchement d'honneur vous dit vous
allez très bien le nommer isabelle je
vous le redis encore vous êtes
magnifique l'âge n'a pas de prise sur
vous ça fait longtemps qu'on se connaît
au moins 15 ans alors oui bah oui
peut-être non quand même pas en dix ans
nous car après 15 en coin bah oui vous
n'avez pas changé vous dit alors je ne
sais pas si c'est un compliment pas mais
je n'ai pas changé
non mais franchement vous êtes toujours
aussi belle oui ça vous intéresse nos
salons ça nous intéresse parce que ça
fait 30 ans 30 ans que vous que les
faits c'est parce que dit on s'en fout
totalement
on accueille 1 300 top top monde a
reconnu le chantier elles sont belles
belles belles comme eux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
réunion du million d'habitants vinyle à
l'aller dominion ouais bah témoin témoin
s'agit-il mais j'ai écouté les chiens
dominion des souriant ces jeunes de chez
nous à ces montants là dit baird et elle
m
[Musique]
2 août
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
présents
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
est l'arrogance est touché merci merci
je cligne on s'était mis à part les
attentions consciente à cape town c'est
parti hancock et surtout mai est
normalement il doit passer par la
fenêtre ne pas pas la porte
c'est dit et la mairie alexandrie
alexander
[Applaudissements]
les gens au prévenu à la dernière minute
donc ces faits précipitamment la ville a
été ornée quand j'aurai toi quand tu y
[Applaudissements]
oui
on voit qu'elle est la fédé bar mitzvah
sur la vie de ma mère on dirait que
vaincu robin ont fait
merci merci mon chéri les chéris on a là
qu'ils ont acquis à les toc toc toc
prochain toc toc toc mais il ne reste
plus que tu n'en as combien 2 2 2 il
risquait donc jean-michel qui benjamin
et moi jamas et qui la docteur knock
méchali mais non mais où jean-michel
rendre à l'essor tu reviens rect alors
je me revois mon kiné con parce que jean
michel vous allez le voir me lafont dans
le rôle et le v'lille à fond dans le
rôle
le problème c'est qu'on dirait pas du
tout que le françois certaines ma mère
on dirait claude françois mais vous
savez donc il veut faire un film x en
croissance
c'est même limite quand françoise excuse
moi tu t'attaques tonnes d'aidé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mêmes faits relatifs
je ne sais pas encore je t'adore s et
une meilleure série je vais m'en lasse
pas c'est pourquoi d'ailleurs la chanson
j'ai même pas écouté ses pas
[Musique]
s
[Applaudissements]
on ment pas
les séries allez on va accueillir jean
michel maire jean michel mr asie alors
vas-y fais ton toc toc toc toc toc qui
est là claude lefrançois banane si le
sniper officielle à et je me demande
comment voulez vous que je réponde ces
gens et c'est cyril qui choisit c'est
mon ami
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il a pris cher
[Applaudissements]
non non excusez moi alors moi tu sais ce
qu'est ce qui nous promet qu'elle
faisait passer par la fulgurance était
prévu que les équipes sinon c'est une
petite initiative mais c'est pourquoi la
chanson j'ai pas compris parce que je
vous jure que je vous racontais la
rigolade c'est que depuis tout à l'heure
je le vois tourner donné et je te vois
répéter une la chanter le mal aimé et en
fait vous aviez préparé des paroles
et/ou bah oui bah je me casse le cul je
bosse un chef ne vous cassez plus rien
je vous dis ne vous en mettez plus est
comme ça l'est